[Music]
michael joins us in phoenix michael
welcome to the ramsey show
yes hi george rachel thank you for
taking my call i hope you guys are
better than you deserve we are for sure
how are you doing
well pretty good pretty good um so a
couple questions well one major uh
a little bit of background uh
just became homeless back in september
gives you some unforeseen circumstances
sorry um
but i'm a single dad two kids um trying
to uh
uh build back better if you will
and um
have a great job
um but
don't know where to don't know where to
start really i
got my emergency fund in place
got into a cheaper car got into a
cheaper apartment
and just really trying to
take control of my finances so my
finances aren't taking control of me
anymore yeah
well it sounds like you're you're doing
a lot better than you were
not long ago so you're in an apartment
now you've got somewhere safe to stay
and the kids are safe
yep absolutely and you've got the job
what's your income
uh
don't know the uh annual but at 26 an
hour i'm a drunk driver truck driving 26
an hour that's great
and uh are is child care a part of the
equation here
no negative okay
good good and you have debt
uh
i don't know how you would label
consumer debt but creditor debt
okay how much debt is owed currently
uh student loans car
a couple of hospital bills
right around thirty
thirty thousand
okay and you've got an emergency fund in
place how much is in there
uh about 1200
1200 bucks so you're right you've got
that baby step one going that starter
emergency fund and you have a reliable
car and you've got a place to stay and
you can afford the the rent there
correct okay
well you're honestly i'm i'm impressed
it sounds like you've been through
a whole lot in the past i don't know a
few months how recent is all this
uh some pepper
wow
man you are resilient yeah michael
you've done you've done an amazing job
do you know that right
uh well it's my kids uh i i work for my
kids i work for my kids i love my kids
yeah
well it's a good why in there because
what you've been through is
i mean it's hard it's really hard and
especially if you're the
sole provider of that i know the weight
that that
feels and that responsibility that you
feel and i feel like the thing that
sucks about money is that you know your
past decisions they do follow you you
know you're having to face these things
that you're like man
i hate it but um
but you you have not let it completely
just overtake you or define you i mean
you really have i hear it in your voice
of i'm gonna i'm gonna do something
different because what i did didn't work
and so i'm willing to change and do the
hard work
to dig myself out of this and i just
think that's like it's just really
impressive and really brave to to make
big changes like this in your life
michael so i just i want to encourage
you in that
um and that this that this debt it is um
is it all in collections because you
were talking about creditors
incorrect yeah it's all online questions
okay
well
one positive note in some of that maybe
not as much the student loans but the
other stuff there are chances that you
can negotiate with them when it gets to
this point
um and and once you get some money um
let's just use like one of them for an
example what how much would you say is
on the car for instance
uh 16
16 000 okay
so you know working to
to get some cash and sometimes they will
settle with you um
and to say hey it's been x amount of
time and here's what i have what's the
best thing you can do
um for me what's the best deal you know
you can give me i mean there's always
that strategy as well that um is a
possibility not that it's all in
collections but
um if that doesn't work then obviously
kind of just chipping away at this and
it'll be it'll be a marathon you know
it's not gonna happen
uh overnight like we say around here but
uh getting those quick wins of paying
off that smallest one is going to be um
it's going to be exciting
what is your smallest step michael
uh about a thousand okay okay awesome
well you got 1200
in the bank so you know you can do it
you know you can work and save that um
so that'll feel that'll feel real good
when you when you hit that first one out
yeah so if you're following the baby
steps we talk about the four walls and
it sounds like you've got those covered
that's food utilities shelter
transportation once we have that covered
you can move on to that starter
emergency fund which you have and then
next up we're going to list those debts
from smallest to largest depending on
what's going on with the creditors and
like rachel said the older the debt has
been in collections the better chance
you have of settling and so if i'm you
right now i'm gonna work my tail off
maybe that means taking a second job
doing anything to increase income and
cut down expenses to create that margin
so that we can save up you know eight
thousand dollars and go to that car loan
and say hey i've got eight are you
willing to take that today and be done
with this and a lot of the times they'll
say we'd rather have some of the money
than none of it yeah and they'll take
that and that can be knocked out in
medical bills especially a lot of those
can be negotiated down
especially with hardship and income so
do your research and be proactive
communicating with the creditors uh you
know call them once a week give them
updates i want you to bother them more
than they bother you uh
they're gonna want you off their back
instead and so you've done an incredible
job obviously i want this debt out of
your life as soon as possible so that
you can really start to create that new
financial future for you and your kids
how old are the kids
14 and 12. wow awesome that's awesome
and are they are they in school what's
their situation
school full-time okay awesome
that's good that frees you up to be able
to to work are you uh back home every
night with this trucking gig
oh yeah yeah i'm local okay that's great
news
well uh you know the good news is the
trucking industry is in high demand and
so you might even look into what other
jobs are out there can i increase this
income is there overtime i know that can
be difficult in the trucking industry
with
regulation but just doing whatever you
can for the next you know maybe it's two
years to knock out this debt especially
if you can settle some of it it could be
shorter than that and once you're
through with that you get that fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then you can rest
easy at night and start investing for
your future how old are you
36 36 dude you got your whole life ahead
of you
you've got a whole new life to start a
new legacy to build with these kids and
uh i mean you know what to do and i i
think you're going to do it you're a
resilient guy nothing's going to stop
you at this point from where you were to
where you are today and where you're
going to be
that's right
and my kids have a full life ahead of
them and i want theirs to be better than
mine
and it will michael i mean honestly
financially yep i mean you're you're
literally making doing the steps right
now
to what we say around here all the time
is changing your family tree and that's
exactly exactly what you've been doing
do you feel more hopeful today than
than even
three weeks ago like as you start really
making progress and you save and and
you're feeling kind of the traction of
this working how how does that feel i
was
i was able to pay off a creditor last
week and it felt amazing amazing it's
discouraging when i can't do it every
week but
it you know it gives me hope yeah
and that's awesome well you keep taking
one day at a time keep busting your butt
for this family clearly that's your why
so let that y fuel you along this
journey and start to dream of what that
future looks like and what it looks like
to maybe being a home one day or be
doing the job you really want to do and
the kids going to college and just start
to dream about that future and that's
going to keep you going every day that's
what you need right now is that daily
motivation
listen to this show for motivation get a
community around you if you don't have
any right now some friends who can cheer
you on along the way some family that's
really going to help you get through
this journey
no thank you absolutely michael thank
you so much for the call we are cheering
you on my friend
yes what a good dad i know i'm just
impressed by this guy and it sounds hard
like the road he just explained i'm like
oh that i mean it's hard yeah and yet
choosing to say okay i'm i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna i'm gonna figure this out
get another job
find an apartment i mean all of it
that's that's so courageous to me
because
there's a lot of you know and i get it
but there are some it's just like i
don't even know what to do they're stuck
and they can't move it's almost like
they're paralyzed by fear but he didn't
really know really digging in and said
okay i'm gonna do something different
and i'm gonna change what i've been
doing which is uncomfortable in the
first place let alone
his life situation so i think it's
amazing us up or come visit us to do
your debt-free screening that's right
from homeless to debt-free that's a cool
story